well hello uh this is danielle dimartino
booth and i'm obviously not in a studio
i am at bobby vans in downtown
new york and i am sitting with the
legend himself
arthur cashion
core director
you tell me arthur is december 30th 58
years is that possible um
it's somewhere in there yeah it's it's
66 68 somewhere in there 64 december 30
yeah right right right
so um
you weren't always
you and i were talking about children
who went to military school you attended
xavier high school
yes here in manhattan i
went to take
they had competitive admission tests in
those days and
um
i was lucky enough to win a full
scholarship i could have never afforded
to go there
and they were
2400 kids took the test and they gave
out four scholarships and i was lucky to
get one of them
[Music]
but i didn't think i could actually
afford forget the uniform it was a
military school
i didn't even think i could afford the
car fare to come from new jersey
[Music]
but the
monsignor who was pastor of my
local parish
paid for my uniform and
i had originally gone
to the
nun who was in charge of my grammar
school and asked her
for papers to go and take the test for
the local
jesuit high school saint peter's prep
and she said
no and i said no and she said
no you won the scholarship and it's
god's will that that's where you go
so
i had no choice and
we managed to scrape through
and then my dad died when i was a
senior in high school so i had to pass
up potential scholarships to college
and
came pretty much right to work in wall
street
with no college education
and
which
i know
you have children as my children were
growing up
and they started to reach that
rambunctious age
they would say what do you know you
never went to college
so
as a defense
i sent away for an application to mensa
and they took me without even having to
take the test
so i've been a lifetime member of mensa
so whenever the kids
look up they
somewhat more quiet no less surly but
somewhat more quiet that that will do it
my father was indeed a member of mensah
himself
so what was it like to be
18 years old you started out as a clerk
absolutely
i came here in 59 and became a member in
64.
so it was a pretty pretty rapid
move up was it common to have 23 year
old members
no
i when when i came out
i think the youngest
people on the floor were about 45 or 50
years old
there hadn't been a large growth after
the
second world war
until the eisenhower years and as i said
i came into the business in 59 so that
was the tag end there so wall street had
not really the the market had done well
but wall street had not really picked up
quite yet it hadn't become
a populist instrument you know people
owned maybe a few mutual funds
but mostly their relationship to the
stock market
was through the pension fund of their
company
so
no it was
it was very interesting i
got my education
in bars like this
which had an encyclopedia behind the bar
to settle bets
and
one of my
instructors if you would was a guy i
call professor jack
he was a
trader over the counter in silver stocks
but he had more in his head than 14
university libraries
and
the things you can learn
from
average humans about real life
i'll give you a classic
we were
not quite to the
cuban missile crisis but we were
certainly getting there and i was
still not a member yet
but
in the early 60s
and
word spread that
something had happened and the russians
had actually pressed the button
and that the missiles were flying
and the option market wasn't on an
exchange in those days it was
over the counter and you had to call
around
i had virtually no money and i was
looking to see if i could make if you
would
100 bet by buying a put or some such
thing
and
everywhere i called i couldn't get
anything done
so i cleaned up and i rushed down to the
bar
and
professor jack was already in the bar
and i came bursting through the doors as
only a 19 or 20 year old would
and i was yelling jack jack
the rumors were that the missiles were
flying and i tried to
and he said
kid
sit down
buy me a drink that was tuition in the
school i went to
the
class class lasted as long as i could
afford the drinks or jack could talk
after having the drinks
but
he said to me ken sit down
and i sat down and he said now listen
carefully
when you hear the missiles are flying
you buy them you don't sell them
when i looked at him and
19 20 years old i said you buy them you
don't sell them
he said of course
because if you're wrong the trade will
never clear we'll all be dead
and i said oh my god that's a lesson you
will never learn in harvard
or in the tough school
so in
bars like this
i got a world of knowledge
and it has stood me in good stead all
these 60 some odd
years and years
[Music]
well
that was the funny thing when
i went to payne weber
and they
asked me to come and talk
at the institutional meeting in the
morning before the opening
and
because i have a big mouth i never know
when to shut up i would go to the
meeting and
i would discuss what was going on and
then one day
apparently the
the phone lines
between the branch offices i think one
of the branch offices in atlanta and
somewhere else
and
they wound up plugged into the meeting
so they started calling up to the
divisional manager and said who was that
guy
and he said who was what guy
and they ultimately found out it was me
talking at the
institutional meeting and they said
our salesman want to hear that
so
i was plugged in then also to each
regional branch collectively
and i started to
write the cashen's comments
to make sure that my memory didn't
become too convenient oh danielle i
never exactly said that
what i said was
so to discipline myself
i started to write them down
and
realizing how difficult difficult it was
for many of the advisors
i would start
each day
with a little vignette
on this day in history
and
i did it because while i was not in
sales
i realized how difficult it would be for
everybody to say we like ge
we still like ge
we're very happy with ge
and if they could say
do you know what happened today a
hundred years ago
do you know what happened today 1400
years ago
and it gave them
a chance to talk to the client
and
break ground for a new day
and say you know your portfolio
could use a little help here i think we
want to be out of the text or whatever
and it became a big standard and
well
it was
faxed by people to friends and friends
and friends and
our mutual friend john walden once told
me that
with all the people he talked to across
the country
he thought it wound up being refacts to
several hundred thousand people every
day
and
um the the repetitive nature of history
is helpful you know
the supposed quote of
mark twain
history doesn't repeat but it rhymes
it comes very close to repeating
there are
fascinating things
as i read and read you know francis
bacon said reading maketh the full man
and
lacking my education i think
i
help myself by being a voracious reader
and you see time and again
things through history
that are repetitive i mean
the the
when alexander graham bell
and his father-in-law
were running out of money trying to
protect the patent on their new device
they went
to
the board of western union
and said we'll give you the rights to
this product
you can own it you just have to help pay
all legal defenses
it was i think less than a hundred
thousand dollars
and
the board of western union said
oh
you don't understand
we're in the telegraph business not in
the telephone business if they had
realized that they were in the
communications business
they would have owned the world 10 times
over and it has happened again and again
and again
the brilliant boards of major
corporations
get marvelous opportunities
and i pick it up and i read it and say
you poor fools
don't you realize you're doing what
western union did
so
reading make it the full man or woman
and
i encourage
all the viewers to encourage your
children
to
find out history learn from other
people's mistakes will be very helpful
to you absolutely
i first came to wall street and i was
working as a clerk and
my first salary
was 39 a week
and
and and
at the place where i started
i looked and saw there were guys there
who were working
at the place for 20 years
and they were making
105 a week
and i said to myself
this is not for me this is this is not a
growth opportunity so anyway
i wound up changing jobs and
did get an opportunity but
at those low salaries
i thought we could
do something so i put together
a singing quartet
got three other guys
and it was the time of things like
the kingston trio and joan baez and
bob dylan was just starting out as a
beginner with folk singers
and
being the somewhat garrulous person that
i've become
as a teenager i talked our way
into
an interview and audition
with the chairman of abc paramount
records
so we went out we bought sweaters so we
all looked alike like we were part of a
team
and we went up
and we sang i think four songs for the
chairman and for the
a r assistant that he had
and he said you know you guys actually
sound pretty good
and we don't have
any folk groups
we just hired a guy from atlantic
records if he doesn't work out
i'm going to get a major album thrust
for you guys and we'll take you
nationwide
and as you have already heard the guy
from atlantic records happen to be named
ray charles and that's why i'm still on
wall street
in the same way the nun said god wanted
you to be there
i'm here
[Music]
yeah well it was uh
when i came as i said they hadn't
experienced
the major blowout there was
the main room which is the room you
often
see and you know it's the room in which
the rostrum is from which people ring
the bell to open and close the market
the
constitution of the exchange
updated through 1929
had
1366 members
to be a member of the stock exchange
which meant that you could
walk up to the floor and trade
every
stock was traded at one location
if you had an order to buy telephone and
i had an order to sell telephones
we couldn't sit here and trade we'd have
to go over to where telephone was traded
and that had a great benefit
because it centralized the marketplace
everybody had to go to that one spot
so even though i wanted to buy telephone
this guy next to us turned out to have a
better bid so you got a better price
when you sold it
so
when i came down all of those
1366 seats
were not active
later on as you
say they became active and then you had
support staff you had clerks
you had
the pages or runners
who
i would be
executing that order and
once i'm finished with the telephone and
i've got to go over
and buy general motors
rather than walk all the way back to
where i was
i'd raise my hand and yell squad or boy
and in those days they were mostly boys
and they come over and say
take that back to payne webber
in booty
and he would take it back to my clerk
who would report it up and i would move
on to the next case so by that time
between the members and the clerks and
the staff
and the squads
probably about 5 000 people on the floor
and
they we had the main room the garage
they expanded it
into
a ramp up to 20 broad
which was called the
blue room
and not because people were depressed
there although that happened in a bear
market
but
because the walls were blue and the
ceiling was blue
and then
the business got even bigger
and they knocked down the petition to
the room next door
then that was called
the expanded blue room because they got
out of creative name
and
then ultimately
they built a
ramp across
exchange place here
and we went into
30 broad street which is right across
the way from where we are right now
so but i will
tell you this it is unlikely
to help the viewers
but
each one of those things
when they
expanded into the blue room
was when we had
the
dot-com bubble collapse
and when they expanded into the ebr was
the next collapse so
if by any chance you hear the exchanges
expanding
sell a little bit of what you've got
right
um
right and sometimes
even
more differently
so there was a day in 1964
that something was going on
yeah actually um on that particular day
i was
upstairs i hadn't gone to the floor yet
and it was a quiet day
and the phone to the floor rank
and our floor broker the guy who
preceded me
a wonderful guy named tommy mckenna
called up and said is there anything on
the tape
about the president
in those days you didn't have the
computer news ticker in front of you or
heaven forbid an iphone
the the
news ticker the dow jones news sticker
looked a little bit like
a dormitory refrigerator it was about
that big
and
the paper would
spew out the top printing on it
and
our new sticker was about
10 steps back
but i was pretty sure there was nothing
on it because
they had alert signals
and if
something like earnings was coming out
or car loadings
the
new sticker might beep once
saying
pay attention we have news if you want
to come read it
it went
two would mean maybe it was interesting
earnings
and then three in a row would mean
something important had happened
so
there had been no
ringing of the bell and
suddenly the
market started trading down
now i've lived through markets that
traded down a thousand points but back
in those days
a few small points run up
and soon the dow was down
20 points and that was pretty
significant and it was headed lower
and
the phone rang again and tommy said are
you sure there's nothing
out about the president
and i said no why do you ask
and he said
well i'm
you know i do two dollar brokerage for
merrill lynch
two dollar broker was like a part-time
contractor
if merrill lynch got busy
and their brokers couldn't handle
everything that they had
they would hire tommy or somebody
and
he would execute the orders and charge
them
a small part of the commission for it
so he said
meryl is giving me orders
everywhere
and their sell orders and i said why are
you selling
and the broker said to him i don't know
but i hear it's something to do with the
president
well about
15 minutes into it
the news ticker ranked three bells i
walked over
and there was a headline
and it said
shots reported fired
at kennedy motorcade
president kennedy had gone to dallas
and
before i could actually get back
and some 10 or 15 steps
three bells again i turned
and said the
president reported injured
and i turned and
three more bells
taken to parkland hospital
and at that point they closed the
exchange
and and
it was still
time to go that was down about 35 or 50
points
a large amount for those days
and it always always puzzled me and then
several months later
i heard a magnificent story
and you know presidents did not travel
around much in 1963.
so he came to dallas
[Music]
and
merrill lynch happened to have an office
in dallas not a lot of brokerage firms
did
dempsey tagler a few other people
so what apparently happened was the
manager said
look the president's in town
and i know you guys are interested
uh i'll keep a skeleton staff here
and you can go all out on the sidewalk
and watch the parade with the president
they all went outside
and in a few minutes
looking sullen and disappointed
they came back in
and
they started going back to their desk
and he said
what are you doing
he said the one of them said the parade
got cancelled
and he thought for a minute and said
what do you mean the parade got canceled
now they were nowhere near
the texas school book okay with the
grassy knoll any of that that was all
blocks and blocks up the hill
but
these people waiting
at the sidewalk for the parade to come
down
looked up those eight or ten blocks
saw that the lights go on in the fire on
the police cars
and the parade turned right instead of
coming down where it was supposed to go
so they're all solely going back
and the manager who is a perfect example
of what i like to think is the right
thing to be in wall street
it didn't make sense to him
so he called all the salesmen into a
huddle
and said
give me a bullish reason
to pull the president of the united
states out of a parade
it's not to sign a tax bill that can
wait
it's not to do this it can wait
why do you interrupt the parade and pull
the president of the united states
out of an important scheduled parade
well no but no they didn't hear any
shots nobody thought assassination
but they're thinking missile crisis
nuclear disaster flood a volcano
something
and he said
100 bad reasons and no good reasons
and he said okay
start selling for the discretionary
accounts start calling all your people
up
tell them we don't know what it is what
we think there's bad news the
president's parade got cancelled
and pretty soon
they were selling and jamming up the
merrill lynch lines
and i am told later
that merrill lynch
called down to the dallas branch manager
and said what the heck are you doing
what's all the selling about
and he said
give me a good reason to pull the
president out of a parade
and they said
you start drinking this early down there
what are you talking about and he said
no
they canceled the president's parade and
we know it can't be good then that's why
we're selling
and that's why
10 to 15 minutes before anything hit the
tape
merrill lynch was selling because a very
bright manager
was clever enough
to think of what went on and that
and that happens time and time again in
chicago
one day and
i can't
completely remember the name of the
brokerage firm it happened to be a small
regional firm that was in chicago
and in those days
almost every brokerage firm had a bench
in the back where customers would come
in and
sit down and watch the ticker go by and
see what the market was doing
and
apparently
it's early in the day 11 11 30.
and one of the salesman looks back and
he sees
the local pharmacist sitting there
and they said to him
doc
what are you doing why aren't you
you know out with the lunch crowd
that you know he had a lunch counter
and he said
no i had to close down
what do you mean you had to close down
is the the the uh
bureau of health shut me down oh the
tuna fish sandwiches is that what
happened
he said no wise guy that's not what
happened he said they're checking on
some product
he said
what do you mean they're checking on a
product
they had some difficulty with the
and they're in here checking through all
my supplies of that product
he said what product was it
he said tylenol
the guy picked up the phone give me
research
who makes tylenol
and he found out it was mcneil labs
which was a subsidiary of johnson
johnson
and
because he was smart
he knew an hour before anything hit on
the new sticker
and that's why this is one of the most
fascinating businesses in all the world
if you pay attention that tape tells you
what's going on
with
with a computer in your pocket or your
pocketbook it's tough i mean
steve jobs knew he couldn't say to
everybody you need a computer in your
pocket he had to tell them i'm going to
build you a phone
so now you have in your pocket or your
pocketbook
the phone that has more computing power
than we had when we went to the moon
all in one little package so you're
right it will be difficult
but sometimes
it's it's not there if you have a minute
i'll bore you with one more story
um
i'm
standing one day
matching and that
next to watching grass grow that's one
of the dullest things you can do it
means that
i'm bidding
for a stock i want to buy it on the bid
side
and perhaps you or someone else is there
bidding for the same stock
and
sometimes we take turns or you might
have a silver dollar in your pocket and
you would match
and if you didn't match me then i bought
it or if i didn't match you then you
bought it for your customer but it's
very dull
i was standing there watching the tape
and the guy who was standing with me and
matching
said
you're watching indiana
and by that he meant standard oil of
indiana
and of course
not wanting to embarrass myself i lied
and said sure
and
so
we were watching
indiana
and then
he looked up and he said
and
and you're watching amaco too
of course
and he said
there's something
there's something wrong with the oils
they're uh
they're trading down and the other
international oils are trading up
so i pretended that i had noticed it too
and i said yeah i was watching the same
thing
so he said
probably trouble in the middle east
of course right
but
the international oils were trading up
so
that didn't quite fit
and then he said to me
the trouble must be on the border
between
egypt
and libya
and
it wasn't
amaco was occidental
and
i thought for a minute an occidental
uh what what little
oil there was in libya occidental had
almost a monopoly on it
and
indiana standard oil of indiana it was
virtually no egyptian oil but what
little there was
indiana had it
so i said okay that makes sense
so then
he said to me
are you watching cone mills fabric
company
no why he said
the trouble must be
on the north end of the border
and i said
north end of the border
and he said yeah he said
you know
all those
women buying the italian genes
he said well
given the special cotton they have in
egypt
they go there and cone mills just built
a mill
up near the mediterranean where they
could take it turn it into denim
and and
prepare it and
slap a italian label on it and charge
women 200 for a pair of jeans
so i said
yeah you're right
day closed nothing happened
indiana had been weak
occidental petroleum was weak
nothing on the news sticker
stopped at 12
went home to the house
kicked the dog beat the kids
turned on the tv
and the guy who came on
after cronkite
but before it might have been roger mudd
it might have been one of those guys
but
i
built myself a robbery
turn on the news
and he said
here's a late bulletin
u.s forces are being alert because
egyptian forces are being
masked on the border with libya
sadat had been assassinated and they
assumed
that
gaddafi in libya
had sponsored it
and then
he blew me away as i was taking my
second sip of the drink
he said
the sources don't know
if the potential invasion will come
by land or by sea
since the forces are messed at the
northern end of the border
and i finished my drink and i said i got
to pay a lot more attention to cone
mills so
the mysteries are still there
they're a little deeper but you got to
know how to find them
about the federal reserve but before i
do
that's your special
are you talking about
the unfortunate day we had in the market
monday
yes
that was special
i remember and again the market
very few things happen in a total
isolated manner
and
the dow had kind of topped out
as it did in 1929
shortly after labor day
and it started to drift lower and it was
getting weaker
and
there was real concern
about the fed and where things would
well it was first concern
was about
another upbeat in potential inflation
and uh
you know
were we going to get to see volcker and
instead along comes to my show as you
said
and
the dow sold off
okay
in one day
prices were falling
it was
as if you were
in one of those dream sequences in a
movie
things
you looked at the order
and you looked at the tape and the price
and you said to yourself this can't be
happening okay
and and
you saw prices absolutely melting and
this has been fired as circuit breakers
oh yes yes
and
although
as we would later discover the circuit
breakers
sometimes can be
like lifeboats painted on the side of
ship
they're very reassuring
but not helpful if the ship is sinking
okay
[Music]
yes
you in dallas texas that you you might
remember that well although you were
probably just in swaddling clothes at
the time
it was dramatic and everybody had
had this
recollection
of volcker
uh
the fed and its involvement
not only on inflation
but uh you know
for
people even adults nowadays when you
tell people
that the prime rate
was 22 percent
and that
mortgages
were 16 and 17 percent
and people
happily took them and paid them off
but but it was the fact that
a very dramatic person like mr volcker
told them that the fed could mean a
great deal
and along came
alan greenspan
and
began to chat about
the market and
that things can get to extremes
the fed has always been remarkable
in that it
tries to divorce itself from things
and by doing so always seems to get
deeply entangled
and so he was just trying to you know
don't be upset it could be irrational
exuberance it's just
something passing by
himself
yes
what was happening
was
when the market began to melt down
many of the
specialists
had trading accounts
people like bankers trust and others
had
gone around
and
solicited them the over-the-counter
traders you know let us
have a special loan for your trading
account
it all seemed
reasonably good they would either close
flat on the day or with small positions
so everybody was
very comfortable with it
except for the
next day
and and
when
the
chairman
banker's trust or whatever
i guess was i can only since i'm
imagining this folks i don't know that
it actually happened
but the chairman of bankers trust got
into his limo and picked up the wall
street journal and sees that
the dow had collapsed
well you know
we can't have any exposure to that can
we and he learned
that they were very aggressive
in
going out and soliciting the accounts
of the specialists or market makers on
the floor of the exchange
and of course
as jim backus will tell you when it says
b with billions that's up to the
chairman so instead of letting
the guy who knew those accounts
handled it
he began to summon
these
senior partners of the specialist firms
over
and simply said
your account is closed
now
these are the major
traders on the floor of the new york
stock exchange which does 75
of the business in these listed
companies the major corporations in
america
and they
start coming back from these meetings
and
i was a governor of the exchange by this
time
and
they would call me in and say
you may have to stop trading in my
stocks
well why
well
the bank has shut me down
and my my loan line's not there and i'd
say
well let's review it and
one by one i would shut down
pretty soon
25 or 30 percent of the stocks on the
new york stock exchange had halted
trading some of which because of me
so now
john phelan who was president
uh the
chairman of the exchange at the time
came down and what's going on
the
banks are
closing our trading accounts we don't
know that we have capital to make
markets
so he immediately
went upstairs
and
tried to call
the people involved
bankers trusts and others
and couldn't get any help
tried to call greenspan
he was as you say on a plane
headed for dallas your favorite spot and
so he was stuck
he called the new york bed and jerry
carrigan was there
and
jerry
while i didn't know him personally by
his reputation was
a bit rough and tumble
and
finally he said to fail and so what
seems to be the matter
he said well
the banks are shutting down
the market loans for all of the
specialists for the over-the-counter
dealers
the market in general
faded away yesterday we're about to see
a repeat
unless we do something
and carrigan said to him
i got the picture leave it to me
and he called up banker's trust and he
said
this is the president of the new york
fed
i want you to reopen
all the trading accounts
for the specialists in the new york and
the chairman said something like
don't be silly i have an obligation to
my stockholders i have an obligation to
my depositors
and targets it to him
did you
hear who i said i was
and the guy said
he said i'm the president of the new
york federal reserve
i could shut your bank in a minute
just to have a check
you do what i say
but serve
nobody sir and thanks to jerry corrigan
all those stocks reopened
and the 87 crash
didn't turn into something permanent
so
you had some good people there at the
fed
um
[Music]
that tells us
one of the great things
in the business
is price discovery
how do you know what the right price is
i've managed for 60 years to become a
decent broker
because on behalf of my client
i don't walk in with the order on my
head and say
what do you think i can get for this
you assess
the tape the industry you have to know a
little bit about these things
but the greatest
story i ever heard
about price discovery
had to do
with tiffany the
and
j.p morgan the great banker and master
of finance here
tiffany discovered that morgan
just loved diamond stick pins
so
as they did in those days in a rather
courtly fashion
he sent his man over
to see morgan
and he had a
gift box all wrapped up in
tiffany blue powder
paper
and he had an envelope
and finally was allowed in to see mr
morgan
he handed him the envelope which he
opened and read
it was from
tiffany
and it said
my dear mr morgan
i know how much you love
diamond stickmans
in this
accompanying box
you will find one that i think is
exceptional and distinctive
it is very rare
i didn't want to disturb you
if you take a look at it
you may send your man to my office
tomorrow
with a check for five thousand dollars
which is the price
because it is so exceptional
if not
tomorrow you may send your man over with
the box
and the pin is still in it
so
the next day
sure enough
morgan sends his man over
and he's got
the box rewrap
and
an envelope now
for tiffany
and in it morgan wrote my dear mr
tiffany
as you say
the
diamond stick pin is exceptional truly
exquisite
but i think the price of five thousand
dollars
is just a bit rich even even for such an
exceptional piece
enclosed
you will find
in the box
a check for four thousand dollars
i'm sorry in the envelope there was a
check for four thousand dollars
and it said
if you choose to accept it
you may send the man back with the box
with the pin and i'll take it if you
choose not to accept it you may give the
man the check for four thousand dollars
and send it back
and then
keep the pin
tiffany is looking at it
he's a great jeweler as we would learn
later
and he knows he can make money at four
grand
he's making a profit
but i'm good enough
that that's not worth it
so he takes the check for four thousand
dollars
in the envelope and he hands it to him
and he said
you may thank mr morgan
and tell him i hope to do business with
him in the future
but
that's
not right my price of five thousand
dollars was secure
he leaves
he stares at the box for a while
finally tiffany opens the box
and he reaches in
and he finds not the stick pin
but a check for five thousand dollars
and a note that says just checking the
price
and that was what taught me more about
price discovery
than three university
long libraries
[Music]
the marriage
well among other things as our mutual
friend peter buchvar
recently wrote
they've helped disrupt seasonality
and believe me
that was one of the earliest things i
learned
the market
tended to have disrupted cycles
in april and may
sometimes into june maybe may june
and then again in september
and october
and years and years ago that was
understandable we were an agrarian
society
so
in the springtime
when the farmers were planting
they needed
to get money to buy seed and fertilizer
or whatever
so they would
out in the rural banks where they lived
call down loans
and
the banks
would then have to draw on money from
the citibank so you would have this
disruption the money flows and
conversely
when you had
the harvest come in
the factories in the city would have to
buy
the crop from the farmer
and the monies would reverse and there
would be disruption in the banks
for years
i would always know to look for
weakness in september with a possible
bottoming in october
and it happened again and again and as i
say it made sense
back when we were in agrarian society
but after 1929
we were more we had more
smokestacks than haystacks
and but
nevertheless almost like phantom pain
the market seasonality remained
but as our friend peter points out
the fed
has
stepped in again and again trying to
avert what they view as
a disruption and in doing so
they prevent
the market from
normalizing whether it's the seasonality
or anything else
i think
the bed
has
added to
inflationary pressure sometimes when it
would have dissipated mr powell believes
this is transitory
it may be but what may be transitory are
the gaps in between
they
by trying to prevent things
they can cause other problems
and
that has been
a very dangerous thing
markets and price discovery
needs
to work like human respiration
you've got to inhale and exhale
and you can't say
gee the exhaling is no good because
people cough and water
if you only inhale it doesn't work and
yet the fed sometimes thinks
that it wants to make sure you're only
in hell
so
they
they don't mean to be disruptive
they aren't
purposely doing any such thing
but there is an old proverb that the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions and i think we have a
well-intentioned fed
that is leaving us open
to possible surprises and there is
nothing more powerful on earth
not the fed not anything else
nothing more powerful on earth than a
free market that changes its mind
and
if people
i've seen it time and time again
if people believe something is wrong
markets can crash
and as i said before
painted lifeboats on the side of the
ship
can look reassuring but aren't very
circuit effective in february
[Music]
my great pleasure thank you
and thank you all for coming
and i'll remain behind
well
i hope you enjoyed that as much as i did
uh arthur is
is one of my mentors and i've learned
more
about the history of the new york stock
exchange here we are across the street
from that here at bobby dans where
obviously any day can be a party
and while i would normally say
i'll see you next time instead today i
would like to dedicate this down the
middle to the memory of tobias lefkovic
he did his first long-form interview on
wall street after celebrating his 20th
year as chief
strategist at city
um and he recently passed away with one
of the reasons i'm here in new york
today in fact so
if you didn't happen to catch that
interview that i did with tobias
all of his wit and self-deprecation and
humor
and market knowledge is in in there as
well and i think you would appreciate
that so uh i won't say until the next
time because sometimes there isn't a
next time but i will say be well thank
you